you look good yeah oh yeah yeah I mean
you know me I am hitting on you a little
bit a little bit immediately usually he
waits a few minutes but the second you
sat down he's like I'm gonna suck that
guy's dick I'm blushing under my opinion
she's putting out the vibe she's just
putting out the vibe uh uh the diamonds
and the teeth have been a very I feel
like a very hot topic I saw you on
social media letting fans that don't
appreciate the diamonds know they could
go [__] themselves that's right that's
right you know they said you gives you a
little slur right and I'm like that's
the freshness of it it's like every time
you hear it you think dang his teeth are
just all shimmery you know yeah I don't
give a [__] what people say you know
it's just I jumped right on the
bandwagon I didn't have these when only
when it was cool you know I had it when
it was everywhere everywhere then I was
like all right give me nose yeah what
made you make the call
um what made me do it yeah Shaggy he did
yeah jumped on his dick
when he first got no it's just it's a
piece of jewelry you know yeah
also it comes off okay yeah you get like
a mold done you know looks good yeah hey
easy
boom this is jewelry you know yeah I
like it a lot of people think I had them
done like yeah that's what I thought
yeah no no yeah so what brings you to
New York man
um I'm on tour the three-headed monster
tour it's um right now Shaggy is doing
his tour a solo tour you know and uh
I'm doing a tour with esham the Unholy
and Ouija Mac and we're doing the uh
three-headed monster tour which we all
perform on stage together I do ICP songs
Ouija these acts are like really big in
the Juggalo world you know so like um
yeah it's something different you know
and and we we perform as like a three of
the monster and we dropped an album
called obliteration probably I think two
months ago and we did the first leg of
the tour you know and uh we rapped as
like literally a three-headed monster
crushing through the city you know
that's awesome Rampage [__] that's
awesome yeah and then and then um and
then oh good then I can hear and then
and then we um and now we all sudden
drop one today out of nowhere wow we
[__] hustled hustled our ass off and
made another album in like two weeks and
dropped that today by surprise just to
support the second leg you know that's
old school dropping an album that you
record like that's how they did it in
like the 70s and the 60s they didn't
take eight months for a record it was
like two three weeks maybe a month and
it was done that's right that's right
and
um this year it's like ICP is kind of
taking off you know so what that means
is we're only doing our annual events
which are you know Hollow Wicked uh
Christmas uh big baller Christmas party
uh Juggalo weekend you know which is
always in a different area every year
um and the Gathering right yes and we're
just playing a few festivals so that's
taking a year off of us the clown paint
makes it so that you guys are forever
right there physically you're like
there's no you know exactly who that is
the minute you see both your faces it's
it's oh yeah that's awesome and it
changed things change all the industry
the right the programmers the radio
programs the promoters all that [__]
rolled over it's new people now right
right and the new people don't hate on
us like that you know what I'm saying
that because when we used to step on
that stage it was it would have been
back in the day when we we were
considered competition right to to what
the bands they're looking at or whatever
but now that we've been here and we're
basically still surviving in our own
world we're not shoving our [__] down
anybody's throat you know people are
just like they're all right where did
you perform at that Festival say it
again what songs did you do it oh we
just did one we just did chicken hunting
nice yeah perfect we just figured that's
what we should do in Detroit yeah yeah
but after that we started playing
festivals and now it's like we do
festivals and we have a [__]
incredibly fresh response you know what
I mean it's just totally [__]
different and uh it feels [__] great
you know what I'm saying and when
somebody reviews our music they know
what it is they know what to expect and
they give like a real review back in the
day they're like what the [__] is this
[__] you know what I mean [__] cartoon
joke ass clown rap what the [__] is the
worst album of all time every time yeah
you know what I'm saying and it's like
you know we were written like that in
big magazines big Publications every
time for years you know so it's just
different now people are like yeah we
get there what they do now do you find
that people react differently to you in
the makeup too like no matter who you
are we made Kirk Hamilton a few years
ago and then Gene Simmons came in and he
was made up and to watch Kirk Hammett
react to Gene Simmons like a little kid
there is something about it like it just
it's Larger than Life and it's forever
it's always the same as when I was a kid
exactly the same and even among other
performers they see you differently than
they would without makeup man one kid
you know people say things to
celebrities because they think they're
iron you know they think they'll have
harder emotions you know what I mean
this I was doing a meet and greeting
this kid was like dumb you all right Jay
I'm like yeah you all right bro he's
like I'm good man for real though you
all right I'm like I'm good bro I'm good
right you know he's like yeah I'm just
asking though like you know everything
health-wise and all you all right I said
why you keep asking me that bro he said
man you just look so old
his girl was like oh my God I can't
believe you just said that you know what
I mean and I thought about it now what I
should have did was smack them
serious because he was young you know
what I'm saying because he's probably
looking at 90 [__] all the time or
whatever and he sees me and he's like
what the [__] you know he's young and
dumb right if I would have smacked his
ass every time he told that story for
the rest of the rest of his life they'd
have been like but why the [__] did you
say that yeah that's right you know what
I'm saying you don't say something like
that to somebody you know you got that
guy was aggressive for smacking you yes
but you why why would you do that you
know is he being aggressive or is he
just oh
that's why I didn't punch him I I mean I
wouldn't have punched him I would have
smacked them but instead I was stunned
yeah yeah you know what I mean and not
did it hurt I mean I ever I know I'm
getting old every time I get out of the
shower and see me in the mirror you know
what I'm saying but like I was stunned
to hear it like you know it's like they
used to tell Michael Jackson you know
um you know when he was growing up and
hitting puberty and [__] you know they
see him on TV as little young Michael
then they when they meet to see the
Jacksons they run up to him where's
where's Michael where's Michael he'd be
like I'm Michael right here and they
would say right to his face oh what
happened to you you know yeah right like
right to his face he's got acne or
whatever and they just people think they
don't have feelings you know I'm saying
it's like you come to town you take a
girl out all night you know what I mean
and then at the end of the night you
know you go to kiss her she's like oh
you're doing like oh I got a boyfriend
well why would you go out with me I'm
not gonna say no to Jim Norton asking me
to take him out you know what I'm saying
oh yes
you know what I'm saying I'm just doing
with the experience I know you you were
romantically interested in me but there
ain't no way I'm gonna pass this
opportunity up just to hang out just to
hang out yep I was like oh well [__] you
you know I wanted to go back to the
festival thing because there's a video
that we've watched a bunch of times on
the show that we've always tried to
figure out what exactly is going on I
must have been a festival because
Limp Biscuit was on stage yeah Fred
Durst is performing yeah I just talked
to uh Fred nurse about this yeah and
shags decides to come out
and he tries to land a dropkick and his
form is I mean his form is decent but
just the spatial sure recognition it's
just not there he falls unfortunately
doesn't exactly hit the Dropkick
distance management was not good it
wasn't great but beyond that the idea
that shaggy two dope is drop kicking
Fred Durst in the middle of his set
security rushed in because I guess they
didn't realize whatever somebody drop
kicking the lead singer Limp Biscuit in
the middle of a set why
did your band mate Shaggy tudo attempt
to drop kick Fred Durst in the little in
the middle of Olympus gets said I'm
Gonna Keep It Real 100 please
number one he fell off the wagon that
day
okay that's true okay real talk right
yeah
we
he fell out the wagon that day uh number
two he did not try to hit Fred Durst
you know I'm saying he was simply doing
what it looked like playing just saying
like it was a it was a bad decision I
guess because he but he wasn't actually
trying to hit right Brothers he was
trying to be like stop kick you know
what I'm saying he's playing he's
playing yeah exactly you know what I
mean yeah and he's drunk and feeling
good and he [__] ran out on stage and
threw a fake drop kick you know and uh
Lethal lethal was like [__] that [__]
them dudes you know and I try to talk to
him you know what I'm saying right and
and he just wasn't punching
um responding you know what I'm saying
so finally
in time time went by you know and then
just recently I'm realizing the wonders
of Instagram how you can reach out to
anybody so I [__] pull up Fred and I
was like what's up bro and he was like
sup and I was like dope I was like here
let me talk to you about what happened
you know he's like hey it's rock and
roll history now you know I'm like yeah
that's awesome you know that's awesome
yeah he wasn't man he's cool as [__]
yeah and I also love that that yeah
everybody wants to play wrestler
sometimes sure yeah that's what he was
doing it's fun yeah he was just throwing
a fake drop kick like what's up yeah
cause it looked like he pulled like I'm
sure he could have hit him that's why it
didn't make sense like he could have
missed by that much right no I mean he
had a running space and everything he
probably could have drilled him if he
actually wanted to you know you know
during the uh pandemic I was doing a
show on the WWE Network that I taped but
they gave me full creative control dope
and one of the things that I did and it
was just like a I mean a talking head
show I have a studio in my basement so
they were like well you know we need
content but one of the things that I did
was I did this like 12 min it monologue
segment justifying why the Insane Clown
Posse should one thousand percent be in
the WWE Hall of Fame oh wow like who
else has this like in the world of
professional wrestling especially from
people technically coming from the
outside there's a band that has been in
ECW WCW WWE and then started their own
promotion right there's nothing like
that in the world yeah has that I mean
is that even on your radar it's one of
the coolest things we ever did yeah I'm
doing all that you know I mean wrestling
was always like a money costly thing you
know what I mean it was it was good for
a minute but but um you know it's loving
it you know I'm still doing it right now
you're right I'm I'm [__] with uh
Billy corgan's NWA I saw that yeah yeah
and and um I'm having fun you know
because that's all his promotion right I
don't have to do nothing but be Talent
you know and I [__] love it it's fun
no pressure you just show up and do what
you want to do like I'm a fan I'm a fan
you know like I I'm a fan I used to
wrestle before we actually raped you
know Joey used to be my manager Shaggy
was my manager you know and and he
wrestled too when once a few years later
we stopped independent wrestling when
when Juggalo started to show up at
wrestling knowing that we would be there
without our face paint wow see what I'm
saying yeah because they started to make
the connection hey you hear that that's
them you know such and such and so we
stopped independent wrestling and almost
like a year later we bought our own ring
in our warehouse and we start having
private shows for our friends because
you loved it so much [__] yeah yeah Kid
Rock used to come down Mike Clark used
to come down you know
um a lot of a lot of the bands in
Detroit used to come down we'd have kegs
of beer and [__] the ring in the middle
and and chairs all around in our
warehouse we used to it was fun man
that's awesome did you indeed do you
realize uh you inspired superhuman
yeah I know
superhuman rules we use them in JCW
what made you would JCW make the change
from Juggalo Champion [__] wrestling to
now the more formal Juggalo championship
wrestling you know I don't think we we
thought about Legacy and all that I
it ain't [__] wrestling these guys are
working hard in there we try to put on
good matches you know what I mean but
it's just funny to say right yeah it was
in the beginning we were just making it
as Oddball as we could you know what I'm
saying like Jim you know Cactus Jack the
wrestler sure in JCW he was known as
Cactus sack yeah it's funny
[Laughter]
there's all kinds of freshness yeah
but um yeah like it's really cool uh
talking and hanging with Billy [__]
Corgan man yeah you know he he I was
flipping through Instagram yesterday and
I seen Billy Corgan I playing on stage
right first of all when I went and saw
him last week he looked like he looked
like a satanic cult leader all right he
had [__] a black ring coat on like
what what do you how would you describe
it
like how you're describing it no it was
like oh like like did it go out did it
flow out the bottom went out yeah but it
was like but it was like it was hard as
[__] okay it was just dope and then he
had bald head right and he had makeup
like like two stars like black stars
like on his eyes you know going across
his forward and down his cheek you know
and he looked crazy and he's got his
arms spread out you know and and I was
like he looks like a satanic cult leader
this is awesome I did not think I would
see this at this he would look like this
as a Smashing Pumpkin Show you know what
I'm saying yeah so then yesterday we
going to see him and I told him that
right when I saw him I hope he was an
offender I'm like dog you look like a
satanic cult leader
that's very King diamond-ish
so then I see yesterday
he's standing there again looking
something similar and it pans over and
there's like a chick dancing looking
kind of like a stripper right and then
also this big buff wrestler looking dude
comes walking on stage and screaming at
the girl what are you doing out here
shaking at us get back there you know
and the girl gives him a stunner
right yeah and the guy bumps on the
stage and he's out and then the
guitarist comes over and starts sticking
ahead of the guitar into his neck or
whatever and I'm thinking this son is
Smashing Pumpkin Show
thinking about the non-wrestling fan
Smashing Pumpkin fans I think like what
is this what in the hell are we seeing
if you don't say that woman is beating
that huge Man's eyes
look on stage with the smiling pumpkins
that's awesome this is you know and I
and I sent him to that I sent him that
and I said man it's official you're one
of us now yeah don't even deny it no
more you know what I mean that's a [__]
we kind of [__] we do you know yeah I
love that you're such a fan too like of
other performers like a lot of guys
don't don't like to acknowledge that
that's right you're very comfortable
just being like yeah I love this guy I'm
happy he responded to me man it's so
[__] weird talking to Billy Corgan
for me bro in the 90s and 2000s we were
always the underground struggling and
they were just as big as you could be
they were headlining Lollapalooza they
were [__] all over MTV Darlings you
know yep that was all the type of [__]
we wanted into you know what I mean and
they were like the kings of it for a
long stretch yeah so now that we know
each other I I say that to him all the
time I'm like how the [__] are we
friends yeah when you realize that those
guys see you as a peer like he see he
sees you as just yeah you're from ICP
like he sees you as an equal he doesn't
look at you the way the way you would
have thought he looked he looked at you
as an equal performer I see that now but
I feel like and this is no disrespect to
him it just feels like if we would have
went and not and went to the backstage
area in in 1998 and been like yo Insane
Clown Posse out here can we come back
there and say hi it would have been like
no response yeah you know what I'm
saying yeah even though that's when we
had four albums on a chart right you get
what I'm saying it just we weren't
understood them I don't think yeah no I
would agree with that and I mean and
part of it was because when you guys
blew up I think
so much of it like at the same time the
music really really mainstream blew up
all the controversy and news reports in
this image of what the Insane Clown
Posse was blew up at the same time so
there were people that were just on this
side of it watching all this news
coverage and the gimmicks and stuff like
that that never even got to hear malenko
or whatever it was going like it's too
much yeah I don't want to be involved
you know it's not real music right it's
something else right but I think like it
don't count right and the fact that you
guys are still making not only still
touring and surviving and have this
amazing fan base but still making new
music that is just as accepted as the
old music was nobody does that in music
like at some point it becomes undeniable
right man maybe I think I know I know
life is um as surprising now as it's
ever [__] been maybe way more Drake
posting a [__] picture wearing a ring
Master Jersey yes how what the [__] is
going on
what the [__] how does that make any
sense in any way shape or form you know
what I'm saying it makes literally none
but that's the other thing that you guys
were so far ahead of the game because
you were like I probably haven't assume
because you were wrestling fans with the
merchandising and the graphics and the
new cartoons I'm not buying it though
I'm not buying it he knows who we are
and he did that on purpose I think he
spent a night somewhere and somebody had
a jersey or something there's just no
way he knows no of course he does he
knows there's no one who doesn't know no
one doesn't know honestly it's true I'm
being honest I doubt it I really do I
think it was like accidental like okay
let me put it this way I'm not saying he
don't know who ICP is I'm saying he
probably saw that Jersey somewhere and
was like that's dope he don't know what
the [__] that is he doesn't know about
myself pee on it nowhere it's just our
second album cover ring Master right
very rare album compared to
outside of the Jungle those guys don't
wear anything that they don't know on
Instagram that's with somebody else
drives if Drake has what 15 million
follow he posted like a like 150
insane no I he knows exactly what it is
he wore like a Danbury trashers Jersey
when that Netflix documentary came out
about the the Thrashers crime and pun
penalties crime and penalties was called
it's like a hockey minor league hockey
team but I talked to the guy who he got
the Jersey from that ran the team and he
was like no like Drake literally saw the
doc got obsessed with it FaceTime me
said where can I get a jersey like then
he put it on Instagram like he knows
exactly he knows
that's to show it off he's taking that
picture simply because it's insane
though that just is out of this [__]
world I didn't know what the [__]
thing that's somebody started blowing me
up at like one in the morning or
something when that [__] came out and
and my phone I didn't even know
understand it was him at first like I
was just like huh just don't make no
sense and then uh post Malone rocking
our jerseys you know what I'm saying
um I never met post Malone but we have a
mutual friend you know what I'm saying
so I know I'm you know and then and then
the craziest thing is the [__] um LL
Cool J's tour right he's got to uh wall
behind him that's all right okay this is
what really makes no sense and I'll tell
you why
because what the [__] why if my my name
is on there okay
and if that's meant to be why is it not
ICP
how the [__] is just half ICP you know
it makes no sense it's almost like it's
up there by an accident and but then a
guy interviewed me said let me ask you
something if you were LL and you were
going on this big tour right and you had
behind you in a list of you know Hall of
Fame names in The Hip Hop whatever that
is you know 50 years of hip-hop you know
um when you look at it first and read
who it was
it's on purpose you know but then you
ask yourself why is it just me
just me make no
I mean people sometimes put outcasts
sometimes they put big boys sometimes
they put Andre people put I mean you're
an individual MC as well as part of a
group right
you deserve the credit you gotta you
gotta take the credit on this one you're
you you guys you guys man you guys have
done a lot man yeah you guys have done a
lot and it's not it's not as big of a
surprise to me looking in from the
outside that that stuff is happening
then it might be to you
because you had to you had to deal with
all the [__] before all this good
stuff came right oh I just find it weird
because I never even met LL you know
what I'm saying me and joy have had zero
affiliation you know what I mean like
we're always been so much of an outcast
even in hip-hop even though Outcast but
you still operate you were still in the
same University you were still aware of
each other he knew who you were everyone
knows what everybody is doing in their
business all those guys know you and a
lot more of them probably liked you guys
than said publicly everyone knows I
posted a picture with Faygo on my
birthday a week ago and every comment on
my Instagram was whoop whoop everybody
knows you know it would be dope man
going to the [__] um if if we could
go to something dope like a war show
right yeah bomb ass you know like when
the VMAs last night yeah that would have
been the [__] yeah just pulling up at
the VMAs you know saying me enjoy
getting out something awesome yeah
awesome outfit with a incredibly
beautiful women you know what I'm saying
the walking the red carpet just going up
in there I feel like we're gonna be
arrested
I swear to God I can feel the anxiety
flowing through me thinking about that
I'd be like it'd be two seconds before
somebody be like get the [__] out of
here Sharon Osborne or somebody be up in
there I don't know you know some
industry person mad I'm just so used to
people being mad you know hey when you
guys did Woodstock 99 I remember
watching on pay-per-view being very
confused because that was when it was
like cool for like all like the rock
stars would bring hot chicks and stuff
on with them and everything and you and
shags uh I remember watching as a
teenager and uh as I'm watching you
perform some of my favorite songs there
are gentlemen uh in really good shape
with Halloween clown masks on completely
nude with their genitals out doing
jumping jacks so they're all like
flopping around and everything behind
you know we didn't have any chicks
keeping it real
second of all we wanted to make some
sort of impact you know what I mean so I
think I offered our crew I said anybody
that gets out there naked
um 500 bucks you know what I'm saying
nice and
um yeah they were out there you know
what I'm saying getting that money you
know they're like that's a wild thing to
see as a teenager that's crazy they were
like can we wear a mask like sure you
know what I mean
so you know yeah that was the [__] man
that was different that experience was
always different yeah it wasn't just 500
Juggalos up front right that was a very
cool [__] very great memory of mine
people talk about like it was a travesty
you know and it's like nobody died you
know I'm the only only real travesty was
a assault sexual assaults you know you
know other than that like a fires and
all that's so [__] what they were
ripping everybody off you know what I
mean it's like nobody got burned up in
this [__] you know it's like um I don't
see it as a travesty besides sexual
assault you know I don't see it as like
a um we had a [__] break time we are
honored to be asked to be in that
[__] we were like what it was
like a hundred grand
yeah in 19 24 years ago yeah yeah you
know what I'm saying we were like [__]
yeah and we don't got to change nothing
you know what I'm saying they they told
us this is what's funny they said you
can't bring your stage set and we were
like all right cool and we brought our
stage
we were like bands have bands equipment
and monitors and [__] and [__] you
know cabinets and [__] we bring our [__]
nobody said nothing we set our [__] up
and did it you know yeah what was the
stage set it was just like [__]
effect he wasn't even noticed one that
massive stage right but we're playing
these clubs all the time right we're
playing the same size clubs now we did
our entire career there was never a
point where we went up to bigger houses
and [__] we've been in the same thing
same Lane our whole career you know
could you have gone up and you guys just
resisted it or you're like we're not
even gonna try it man if we could have
gone up we'd have been uh
[__] man [__] yeah we're all about
selling out
good for you
[Music]
in this bright commercial I'd be like
all of it
I'm doing second version you know what
I'm saying I don't have that type of
prod like oh I can't use my music I
think music is a [__] no matter what you
do with it it don't change the way it
sounds you know what I mean so use the
[__] out of it and pay me yeah I'll put
I'll put Sprite in the lyrics that's
what I'm saying I'll do it like Michael
used to singing about Pepsi generation
it is funny how many people get mad at
artists for allowing their music to be
used and make a lot of money not having
to do any extra work it really is nuts
how people get mad at that I don't know
why you know but I I respect it you know
I I I I I respect it man and another
thing you know bands break up right they
fall out right and then they um
they they won't come back together and
people are like man all these [__]
fans want to see you just pull it
together man just [__] get it
together and do it for the people right
it ain't that easy yeah it's not you
know what I'm saying and me and Joey
love each other but we've had partners
that we ran with for 15 20 years and
then fell out with them as artists and
nothing will bring that back yep you get
what I'm saying 100 nothing and and so I
understand that now too right did you
guys ever have a period of time where
you were like yeah this is done who me
and Joey yeah with each other yeah no I
think that's amazing yeah thank God it's
only two of us though right you know
what I'm saying we have such a good
understanding you can always talk it
over it's just one guy you could just
call him and talk it over and work it
out you know and he he wants to do
something he does it there's no way I'm
not gonna have a problem with it it's
the same thing for me if I do something
he's encouraging to it you know